deep within the amazon rainforest a
mysterious creature lurks notoriously
elusive this cave-dwelling giant hairy
monster leaves a trail of broken trees
and trampled ferns in its wake with no
predators to speak of the map in guari's
fearsome strength is matched by its
pungent odor appearing predominantly in
the traditions of the peoples of brazil
the map inquiry seeks vengeance against
those who hunt and harvest the flora and
fauna of its home those are deemed
violators of the sacred spaces of the
rainforest
the amazon claims unparalleled
biodiversity on our globe and demands a
heightened level of protection so is the
mapping wari real mythical or somewhere
in between
i'm dr emily zarka and this
is monstrum
of massive size great strength and
possessing a distinctive foul smell the
hairy creature roars with great ferocity
from its shortened horse-like muzzle the
map in quarry may have two eyes or only
one in the center of its forehead and a
mouth in the center of its stomach it
usually roams the rainforest on all
fours but eyewitnesses also claim that
it can walk bipedally when standing on
its hind legs the map in guari can reach
anywhere between three to six meters in
height adorning all four giant
anteater-like paws are large hooked
claws like those of a giant armadillo
that curl inwards or backward
it also has some pretty impressive
chompers including four huge canine
teeth protruding from its mouth
color variations range from reddish to
brown to black and it has a short tail
while the map in gwari prefers a
vegetarian diet it will feast on
livestock and humans that violate its
habitat it kills by ripping the legs and
arms off its prey before eating them for
the particularly bad offenders that
pillage the forest with greed in the
most brutal accounts the creature
devours the victims slowly starting with
the head and proceeding leisurely
the hard skin of the map inquiry may
resemble the skin of an alligator or a
turtle shell but regardless of
appearance it's virtually impenetrable
to weapons another weak point it's belly
button few get the chance to try to kill
the monster
depending on the source it's horrific
odor or supernatural abilities disorient
would-be hunters
those that might get a lucky shot off
may not even be able to get near enough
to verify the kill because the smell
emanating from the remains is so foul it
cannot be tolerated by even those with
the strongest stomachs the first tales
of the map in guarani come from the
indigenous peoples of the amazon basin
where legends of forest creatures abound
in the amazon across the states of
rodonia amazonas akre and para the map
ngwari is part of folklore and reported
in eyewitness accounts alike brazil is
home to more than about 300 indigenous
groups with great linguistic diversity
with upwards of 150 languages across so
many communities it's typical to find
variations in this monster's name or
story
it is difficult to be sure about the
etymology of the name mapingary but the
main assumption is that it comes from
the tupiguarini indigenous language
meaning a thing with the twisted feet
or
that who has a twisted feet
that's dr andreoli costa folklore
researcher and consultant he's an expert
in brazilian folklore and a great
storyteller to boot
the first reports of the mapingwary myth
date from the turn of the 20th century
and coinciding with the rubber cycle in
the amazon
and it's precisely among the rubber
tappers where we find some of the oldest
stories about the mapingwary other
monsters share characteristics with the
map in guari like the segamai an
herbivore about the size of a cow with
matted fur who can walk on all fours or
its back two legs emits a blood-curdling
roar and cannot be harmed by regular
weapons but has a snout more like that
of a giant anteater then there's the
protective kurupira the feet which we
mentioned earlier are sometimes turned
backwards like the brazilian chlorophyll
and other forest beings who use this
strategy to confuse their pursuers
in others which are the most common
today they say the footprints of the
mapiguri are round like the hand of a
pesto or a bottle
or the bottom of a bottle
like another brazilian meat
called bottle foot
papinberry has a vertical gigantic mouth
in its abdomen
a very similar mouth to another myth
a traditional narrative among the
enslaved africans in brazil
the difference is that the kibongo's
mouth is in the back there are stories
in which the mapingworthy has both eyes
but often they say it has only one
which underlines its bestiality the one
eye the cyclope guy
refers to bestiality the uncontrolled
violence
of those who cannot distinguish
right and wrong
it's tempting to use the similarities of
the mapaguari myth across regional
traditions to connect the creature to an
animal one that lived not so long ago or
even one still alive today
this is where the most popular and
notorious rationalization for the map
inquiry comes into play the giant sloth
theory which claims the map inquiry and
other similar creatures are folkloric
interpretations of a real but long
extinct animal
though in the spirit of other elusive
monsters there are some people who chase
legends to prove their existence
in the 19th century written claims
emerged from south america proclaiming
that members of the milo don today
ground sloth family believed to be
extinct were actually alive and well
argentinian paleontologist florentino a
megino publicly asserted he believed
giant ground sloths still lived in the
patagonia region even in the 21st
century the mapping guardi as a
groundslaw theory is enthusiastically
supported perhaps no more publicly than
biologist and ornithologist dr david
oren
oren has dedicated a large portion of
his life to proving the continued
existence of prehistoric ground sloths
he asserts that the monster is the
result of cultural memories combined
with present-day living ground sloth
encounters most likely a relative of the
milo don today family
some of the hunters oren talked to said
they had even killed members of this
subset of the xenarin-clade species
themselves on one of oren's excursions a
dung sample thought to be evidence of
the creature was collected
using dna analysis a lab proved the true
owner of the scat an arboreal anteater
science doesn't necessarily explain all
of the first-hand accounts or hundreds
of years of narratives there are two
problems with those answers the first is
that if the link between fossils and
meds were that old we would already have
records of mapingwary before the 19th
century the 20th century
and we haven't the second one is that
it's extremely problematic and
colonialists
to condition the belief of so many
populations to the scientific validation
as if they were allowed to believe in
the mckinlery because the megateria
existed
no
we cannot reduce mapingwary to the giant
slot
to do so is to ignore the entire
symbolic framework that runs through
the myth
the name is very important to understand
the myth for example
we find two possible names for mapping
real-life creatures
kidaharara which means lot in beast
probable reference to its mouth
and obojo
meaning maternal grandfather that's very
interesting because
to think of the mapingwory as a
grandfather is to recognize it as
an equal
as a relative
as one of them
like the european colonizers and
travelers who once influenced these
stories western audiences and internet
folklore sleuths today have blurred the
lines between these supernatural
monsters and their indigenous symbolism
while not necessarily done with ill
intent it's important to keep in mind
that the original mapanguari tales hold
the greatest significance
i would invite you to understand my
pingery as a representation of the
arctivic fear of what
desimonizes us
what makes us monstrous best
blind to the suffering inflicted jabber
blind to the castration of our actions
and desires
in the end however
the weak point the belly button will
always be there to remind us that under
all that letter
shall before
that makes us sensitive
there is the human being
that can be assessed again
if we take a close look at all of the
map inquiry stories from various
indigenous communities in brazil there
is a consistent theme the creature's
purpose is to protect the rainforest
for thousands of years the abundance of
riches within this natural resource has
sustained the people of the region
the existence of a scary monster set out
to protect it makes sense
the map iguari avenges its home from
trespassers hunters and greedy consumers
alike
and if the map ngwari's fearsome
presence can help save this significant
resource another monster has served its
purpose
milo dante
t day
milo don today oh yeah duh milo on today
good enough